human chimeras living among us it's only
science fiction for right now
yesterday the senate passed the endless
frontier act a bill that commits nearly
250 billion dollars
to promote emerging technologies so that
america can keep pace with chinese
innovation
back in may democrats shot down an
important amendment
outlawing u.s participation in research
that would create human animal hybrids
also known as chimeras china is already
doing it
announcing in april that an
international team successfully grew
human monkey embryos and sustained them
for 20 days in a lab
the only question is what will they do
next
currently the national institutes of
health has banned u.s funding for
chimeric research
but that ban could very well be lifted
and who's to say that these agencies
will play by the rules
anyway remember president obama banned
funding
for gain of function research back in
2014
but new york a.d found a way around it
uh and they laundered the nyad group and
they laundered hundreds of thousands of
dollars to the wuhan institute of
virology
through a non-profit group called the
echo health alliance
the rest is history chimeric research is
a pandora's box that's
obviously from hell that should not be
opened but the scientific community
spurred on by their own hubris
may very well open it using american
taxpayer dollars
and if that happens the democrats will
have blood on their hands for not
joining the gop and stopping it when
they had a chance
joining me now for reaction i don't even
believe laura logan
here we are it's the 21st century we're
two very smart women we have to talk
about chimeras and how we
maybe the government might do it you've
been very involved in great your
research and stories and coverage on
certainly covid uh what's been happening
there
can give me your take on the seriousness
of this china's doing it and what we
have to be aware of
you know tell me one of the things that
i that strikes me the most about this
story
is there's an old adage you know be
careful of what you don't know
and that has never been more true than
with this subject what exactly
do we not know here about how far how uh
what is the level of involvement the u.s
has had in any kind of research like
this and what else
has the nih and other divisions of the
nih being involved in
because when it comes to uh dr fauci and
what we know about
covert we're just beginning to find out
right we're at the tip of the iceberg in
terms of uncovering
what was really going on with gain of
function research
and the whole sort of smoke screen of
the wuhan lab
really obscures the fact that dr fauci
and the nih
through niaid had been funding gain of
function research for
years and there's a lot of money that's
missing here and there's another u.s
agency
that's missing from this equation it's
called darpa you know
which is the defense research agency so
what were darpa and dr fauci
and the nih doing with gain of function
and various
other programs like this one which
we know so little about and this is
really the moment now for a reckoning
this is time for the american people to
start paying attention to these bills
that pass through congress that get
banned they get
unbanned that gets circumvented and for
us to start um
asking for real accountability because
what we've seen is that the corona virus
you know that spread all over the world
and cause such panic and still causes
such hysteria in so many quarters
well you just speak to someone like an
oncologist who deals with bone marrow
cancer
they'll tell you that they've been
identifying hundreds of coronaviruses
for years and years and so this is one
of many subjects that we know very
very little about and every day that
goes by we get the stench of
manipulation and dishonesty is growing
stronger yeah and i think this is
part of what allows us to find this
information out
you know there's the theory that
ignorance is bliss right and yes
not being aware of things is kind of
peaceful but the fact of the matter is
these things happen anyway and this
particular bill and this is what
congress tends to do
uh was about trying to you know keep up
with china but then it became a
christmas tree
and that it was like over 200 amendments
and all the lobbyists got in because of
course it's going to have to pass so
get in whatever it is you want and this
is what they do without
any consideration about the impact on
the average person
you know covet is one thing right mass
death
here you're talking about changing the
nature of life
and this is what of course is is so
shocking to me we got just a couple of
seconds left but this is a real game
changer
it is and you know what's so interesting
about it to me tammy i'm not
particularly religious
but what it keeps reminding you of we
can create robots that mimic humans
now we want to take animals and humans
and blend them
and we also want to take meat and we
want to grow
uh some version of food this is a
laboratory from the cells of meat but
you know what we can't do
we can't create life we as human beings
don't create life
and no amount of ingenuity and science
is going to change that and the things
that we do laura thank you so much
this is the kind of things that get you
karmically and we've got to stand up for
ourselves
uh and uh for everything that comes up
in the future hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else